[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
albert brier tweeted the following
there's nothing more college football
than big 12 schools fighting over
penalties for oklahoma players flashing
the horns down
sign at texas players while oklahoma and
texas
secretly are conspiring to leave the
conference together
as we welcome in albert breer from the
monday morning quarterback
what do you make of this with uh texas
and oklahoma
thinking about joining the sec i'm more
of like a bison
i love the circus you know what i mean
like i just like the absurdity of
college football
it's it's great and um i mean i guess
this is where we're going though right
like without being somebody who covers
it day to day
it just dan it sort of feels like at
some point and i think we've like been
talking about this for 15 or 20 years
and i love college football right
all you gotta do is look over my
shoulders to see that i i but
but i think it's like where we've been
going for a while now right like where
eventually all of the big powerhouse
schools the big powerhouse conferences
are going to separate themselves from
the rest of the sport and
i mean i this feels like that right yeah
but i wonder what's going to happen with
ohio state michigan notre dame um
usc yeah maybe oregon you know you don't
want to get left out it's a game of
musical chairs and then music stops and
you go wait a minute
what happened you don't have a chair to
sit down on but don't you think like
the usc's michigan's ohio states those
schools
i think are protected because those are
like self-sustaining brands right
like i'd be more worried if i was like
in iowa
or if i was like a washington right like
the teams that have sort of
that are been really really good in the
past but maybe aren't like
self-sustaining brands where they can go
out and sell themselves as a
singular entity like ohio state and
michigan and usc
they could get notre dame television
deals couldn't they if they wanted to on
their own
like i probably right yeah
like so but there are those other
schools i think like that's the thing is
it's like
if you're like say you're illinois
are you worried about something
happening to you
similar to what might happen to say
kansas now
right like it just sort of feels like
that's the sen that that those would be
the schools
where i i think you know that you'd have
to be worried about the big powerhouse
brand names
i think are probably going to be okay
either way and you you have
probably and i i maintain you're
probably going to have three
super conferences and maybe you have 16
teams in each of them and that's it
you just cap it at that um you know
a a program like vandy where you know
they're going to get parting gifts and
say
see you later but yeah imagine if the
nfl did this
if if all of a sudden you said uh hey
we're gonna
bring in robert kraft goes let's bring
in the giants you know we
we want them to be part of our
conference here you know these
these blue bloods the cowboys how
valuable i guess that's why
the way doesn't that the way english
soccer works though with relegation i
love relegation
right like like what if the nfl split
into three and you had relegation
is there any expansion on the horizon
with the nfl
i don't think so just because i i think
the
nfl owners are like so where they are
like they came to a point i think 15
years ago or so where
it was we've done we've grown up as much
as we can
right so like domestically the way the
products been produced over the last
you know however many decades like we've
maxed that out
and so now we've just got to add
inventory right so everything was
growing out that's what london is that's
what going back to la is that's 17 games
expanding the playoffs all of those
different things
you know but they've done it within the
context of 32 teams and the key there
is that pie that they're talking about
you know jerry always says grow the pie
well if they're you're splitting a 32
ways and you're growing it and then
maybe you're splitting it 34 ways at 36
ways
now you got to grow the pie that much
more so i think if they were ever going
to go into
like talking about expanding again like
the growth would have to be exponential
financially where you know splitting it
34 ways of 36 ways
would mean more of a share for each of
the teams than splitting in 32 ways
and you're not going to do that by going
into some middling market you know what
i mean like you have to go to some place
that's really going to add a lot of
value
so i the only way i really see that
happening
is if it's international what about
relocation
[Music]
yeah i mean you know we've always you've
heard more grousing i think over the
last
maybe decade or so about teams pulling
their weight
you know in the cincinnati's of the
world and you know how
like buffalo had the owner's name in the
stadium for that long and how cincinnati
still has
the you know the the name of the founder
of the team in the
stadium and how they're not like doing
rights deals they're not pulling every
lever
financially and they're dragging the
other teams down to begin with because
they're smaller markets
so could we eventually get there maybe i
think what's protected a lot of those
teams
has been the stadium boom and so many of
those stadiums
are like relatively new
and so you know like indianapolis for
example would be a a city where you
would look and you would say
all right like is this city pulling its
weight well
they built a stadium a little over 10
years ago so i think like
the idea of moving those teams with la
off the table now
really becomes a matter of when those
stadiums sort of age out and i think
we're still a ways away from that like
cincinnati stadium is what 20 years old
now
and i'm not picking on the bengals but
you know there are stadiums that are
getting a little older now
you know when those stadiums are 30 35
years old maybe we're talking about
something else again
my caveat on that would be the same
where
the international part of it i think
could come into play
where a city like you know we've talked
about jacksonville forever
like whenever they're ready to go to
london i think that's in a different
category than moving a team domestically
we're talking albert breer the
senior nfl reporter for the monday
morning quarterback
um what intrigued you out of cowboys
camp yesterday with jerry jones anything
catch your attention yeah the jimmy
johnson thing definitely
i mean i know that's not about here and
the now um
but the fact that you know he basically
can see they're going to put him in the
ring of honor i don't think most people
know that jimmy's not in the ring of
honor
in dallas which just seems absurd right
yeah that that seems a little petty
yeah yeah so i mean the fact that he
conceded and
i think he said that like he doesn't
want to do it this year because they
want to honor jimmy for getting in the
hall of fame this year
so they want to do a separate ceremony
for it which is fair
but the fact that he's conceding that
it's going to be done got my attention
now as far as like the here and the now
and the cowboys like today
um yeah i think mike mccarthy is saying
that dak prescott's full go
is huge because i i can remember when
that injury happened and i can remember
talking to people
in january and february where there was
definitely
some quiet concern i mean i guess even
just how dak was moving around at that
point
you know and so this was more i think
you know
this was more than like a torn acl or
somebody blowing out their achilles like
this was something where
there weren't a ton of guarantees on
what he was going to look like coming
back so i think
the fact that he's full go for the start
of training camp
is enormous enormous news even if it's
what we expected all along
then you got steelers camp that's opened
up and those two will meet in the hall
of fame game
i still go back to the steelers went
all in on improving their running game
and
and i didn't know if that's really what
they needed to improve
upon and you could get a running back
and we've devalued running backs i i
like
najee harris but do i like him at that
spot for the steelers that it came as a
little bit of a surprise how about you
yeah and i think i think
a piece of that is like the need to take
the pressure off of
ben roethlisberger's shoulders like i
think it's an acknowledgement he can't
carry the team anymore
and in a lot of ways i mean i guess the
parallel you could
you know draw us to the 90s broncos you
know
what terrell davis did for john elway at
the end of his career
um you know i think they feel like ben
roethlisberger because of his experience
the inventory he has mentally
um his big game experience all that
different stuff
like they can still win with him but he
can't carry the team anymore
and so you know i think that it's an
acknowledgement like
you know we're pretty good at receiver
and if we get him a back
and we create easy completions for him
he's going to take less hits
and so the equation there for for mike
tomlin and kevin colbert was
like how can we make it so this is less
about ben roethlisberger and more about
the team around him lifting him up
now the one thing that i think everybody
has sort of glossed over over the last
six months
alejandro villanueva's gone yeah david
decaster is gone
marquise pounce he's gone and mike
munchak who is the
you know line coach who put all that
together five years ago
is gone too so i think so much of where
the steelers go is going to ride on
their ability to support ben
roethlisberger and not ask too much of
ben roethlisberger at his age
i think getting naji harris was a piece
of that
the bigger question to me is can they
fix the offensive line on the fly and
the steelers have earned the benefit of
the doubt when it comes to drafting and
developing
but there's going to be a lot of
pressure on a couple of young guys up
front to get it done
the team that had the best offseason the
team that had the worst offseason
the team that had the best offseason
i would say the team that had the best
offseason god you know i would almost go
rams but
they just lost cam acres you know so it
would seem like
like i i just i don't know i i have a
hard time going with them
um and the bucks are an easy answer
because they bring everybody back
i'm going to give you a little bit of a
curveball i'm going to say the chargers
um i like their head coach a lot brandon
staley
and i think like they quietly fixed
their offensive line
in a very pragmatic way where they
didn't overreach for anybody
um they got i think guy who some people
would argue is the best center in the
league and corey linsley
and they drafted a left tackle on
rashaan slater who no one thought was
going to be there at 13.
so they got good value in free agency
they got good value at left tackle
they were able to fix both of those
spots without
going crazy and then on top of that
you know they lose hunter henry at tight
end but i think he could argue
if jared cook stays healthy he could be
an upgrade at that position
so i just look at them and what they've
done to support their young quarterback
justin herbert
i think the chargers had an awfully good
offseason
bad offseason i
houston houston i'm so i like
and and i i like a lot of what nick
casario's done there but i just
i think at going through what you went
through with deshaun watson
um all of the stuff with um
you know with jack easter be uh you know
i
think that this you put a lot on the
plate of david cully
um in his first year in houston so i
think it's hard to
answer uh answer answer it any other way
than it's the houston texans who had the
toughest offseason now
i i think nick casario has a chance to
be a brilliant general manager so he's
got a chance to turn around
i think he brought like some really
underrated like you know competitive
free agents into the building
but like i don't know how that's better
than a three or four win team which
i mean look you know you win three or
four games if you're competitive
and you're able to establish something
program-wise maybe you trade
desean watson for a king's ransom and
then
you know we get to april and they're
looking at spencer rattler and sam
howell and all those
different guys in the draft so i mean
you know part of it's sort of where the
franchise is but yeah i don't think
you'd argue they had a very good
offseason based on everything that
happened
always great to talk to you albert thank
you we appreciate your time
thanks dan appreciate it that's albert
breer senior nfl reporter
uh he's the lead content strategist for
the monday morning quarterback